next year the sequel of the celebrated
Wonder Woman from DC is finally on the
agenda the first part released in 2017
worked mostly independently from the
rest of the DC blockbusters and
especially the main actor dual gal gadot
and Chris Pine was well received by the
audience now director patty Jenkins who
also directs the second part called
Wonder Woman 1984 has published her
first poster on Twitter
it shows gathered in golden armor
against hip psychedelic background in W
form
furthermore you can see the hashtag
Wonder Woman 84 and the release date
unfortunately we can't interpret much
about the content of the poster we only
know that Diana Prince will be dealing
with some kind of cheetah woman also
Chris Pine is expected to return as
pilot Steve Trevor
for further information we have to be
patient Wonder Woman 1984 will be shown
on the screen at the beginning of June
2020 in 2012 the revenge blockbuster
Django Unchained by Quentin Tarantino
was released three years later a comic
series called Django / Sora was
published which began immediately after
the event from the original film in the
comics story he meets Diego de la Vega
better known as sorrow he joins him as
his bodyguard
and together they start to liberate
slaves as the magazine Collider now
reports Tarantino intends to bring the
comic book he created also to the
cinemas as a film in addition the US
American comedian and writer Jarrod
Carmichael is allegedly involved however
it is not yet known whether Carmichael
will act as the solo scriptwriter after
his upcoming movie Once Upon a Time in
Hollywood
Tarantino wants to retire anyway which
is why it's questionable whether
Tarantino will take a seat on the
director's chair at all Tarantino's next
film Once Upon a Time in Hollywood with
Brad Pitt and Leonardo DiCaprio will be
released on 26th of july 2019
who would have guessed only last week we
reported that Steven Spielberg would
like to have a new face as the leading
actor for Indiana Jones 5 but now it's
clear that the 76 year old Harrison Ford
will be once again an archaeologist in
front of the camera and not only that
because Ford himself announced at the
same time the start date of the shooting
in an interview with
he announced that the shooting will
start sometime next year he also assured
that things are going well and that they
are finally in the process of achieving
a satisfactory script until we can see
Harrison Ford and his cult role as
Indiana Jones we'll have to wait another
two years
Sponge Bob Squarepants is one of the
cult series of the late 90s and 2000's
now the series will get a prequel called
Camp Coral
the plot is supposed to revolve around
the young spongebob who goes together
with his friends to a summer camp there
the young sea inhabitants learn
jellyfishing and how to light a campfire
underwater in addition the 13 episode
series is not supposed to become the
same as its predecessor because it will
be realized completely with 3d animation
originally the 3rd spongebob film should
have been released in 2022 however no
one knows for sure if the plan is still
up to date unfortunately we don't know
yet when Camp coral will appear in the
cinemas but we expect the release date
in 2021 at the earliest it has been
known for some time that the Fantastic
Four will become part of the MCU after
Disney has taken over Fox many fans have
been hoping for a decent successor after
the rather moderate first part in 2015
Marvel boss Kevin Feige said in the past
that Marvel strict schedule did not plan
to integrate the Fantastic Four in the
near future now however the online
magazine geeks worldwide claims to have
found out from an anonymous source that
Marvel expects a successor to be
released in 2022 it also came to light
that ant-man director Peyton Reed was
heavily involved in the planning and
that he had already submitted several
drafts this indicates that the film will
probably play in the 1960s and at the
quantum level which was important in the
Avengers and came could also play a role
if the inside information is correct it
can be assumed that the Fantastic Four
reboot will be officially announced at
the San Diego Comic Con this year
so if geeks worldwide is right or not we
will certainly find out in the near
future the trailer for The Lion King
remake could almost make you believe
that director Jon Favreau shot his film
with real animals only the fact that the
animals speak makes you think that it's
an animated film in fact the remake was
created completely on the computer which
means that not even the actress stood in
front of the camera for motion capture
shots in a recently published interview
with furfrou he makes it clear that he
doesn't want to call his land King
remake an animated film he is quoted as
follows
well it's difficult because it's neither
really it depends what standard you're
using because there's no real animals
and there's no real cameras and that's
not even any performance that's being
captured that's underlying data that's
real everything is coming through the
hands of artists but to say it's
animated I think it's misleading as far
as what the expectations might be and it
also changes the way you sit and watch
it because hopefully you could just
watch it without it being introduced if
we put up that Rafiki footage and didn't
say what it was
some people might know some people might
not know how it was done but it causes
you to be present and mindful and pay
attention because you're trying to
figure out what you're looking at and
that's a greatest position to be in as
an audience member
sounds like a pretty well thought-out
concept in addition you can read between
the lines that they don't want the Lion
King to be seen as an animated film
since the association with children's
movies is too great here rather an
animated film or not The Lion King
remake will be released on 19th of july
2019 in u.s. cinemas
[Music]
you
[Music]